[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8
week-end de ce vendredi 20 janvier je
viens juin pardon pour parler de la Fête
de la Musique ce sera samedi 21 et en
cette fête de la musique il est
évidemment autorisé de faire résonner
trompette et tambour et en plus c'est
gratuit la fête de la musique allez pour
en parler avec nous autour de cette
table Marc Isaac ou bonsoir responsable
du secteur des musiques amplifiées à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à côté de
boucatrina ta bonsoir vous êtes mère
adjoint en charge de la culture
notamment avoisin le Bretonneux en face
de vous Pascal Romano vous êtes
directeur du conservatoire de Maurepas
et à vos côtés pour pas qu'organise sa
première fête de la musique et à vos
côtés Jean-Marc Le régulier vous êtes
maire de Buc pour nous parler et de la
fête de la musique et puis vous restera
un petit instant encore avec nous pour
parler la huitième nuit de l'Opéra qui
aura lieu dans une grosse semaine alors
on va commencer cette fête de la musique
Honor amour pas honneur au petit nouveau
fait de la musique parce que Romano
d'abord pourquoi pas de fête de la
musique avant
en fait nous étions dans un autre format
autour de la fête de la ville l'équipe
municipale arrivant nouvellement a
souhaité insuffler une nouvelle
dynamique et donc nous a demandé de
rassembler les énergies dans le délai le
plus rapide
donc on a on a fait on a fait appel tout
simplement selon la grande tradition de
la Fête de la Musique appel au musicien
volontaires et amateurs de la ville donc
autant musicien qu'association locale et
puis on a réussi à leur à monter un
format de démarrage on va dire enfin un
premier format qui se passera donc
demain
mais dans un format original puisque
relativement court et dans un horaire
de fait original aussi puisqu'on fait ça
sur un créneau ou la ville est un petit
peu en on va dire en ébullition autour
du marché de Maurepas autour de la vie
économique un un peu et commerçante de
la ville donc le matin à 10h donc voilà
un format d'une heure mais malgré tout
avec une un programme relativement riche
qu'est-ce que vous avez proposé alors on
part on arrive
on part de Schubert et on arrive à nos
jours en passant par donc on a les cœurs
de la Pléiade qu'ils vont nous faire
quelques variations autour de la truite
de Schubert dans un deuxième temps des
percussions djembé donc là le
Conservatoire intervient avec des élèves
qui vont faire un intermède un petit peu
ethnique pour changer un petit peu la
couleur et puis nous allons clôturer
avec le cœur crescendo qui eux vont
chanter autour des de chansons des
années 50 jusqu'à nos jours et je pense
avec une participation souhaitée du
public voilà on va essayer de la fête de
la musique c'est quand même que chacun
arrive avec son kit instrument de
musique franchement des morceaux enfin
voilà et donc là on est vraiment donc
pas de groupe invités pas de pas de
plateau démesuré vraiment une on va dire
plus une une et le souhait je pense de
d'inscrire cette date dans les dans le
calendrier culturel de la ville donc
samedi de 10h à 11h pour ceux qui me
connaissent
voilà donc c'est vraiment on voit le
parvis de la mairie c'est vraiment juste
en face on est en plein centre-ville
juste dans l'allé piétonne qui mène au
marché entre le marché de Maurepas et
l'hôtel de ville donc vraiment avec
toutes les solutions de stationnement
possible voilà et ces piétons donc c'est
vraiment un c'est une zone piétonne donc
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est peut-être
moins repérable qu'un qu'une avenue donc
on va démarrer samedi matin du côté de
Maurepas entre 10h et 11h pour le
premier pour une première fois de la
musique demain matin alors Marc Isako
vous alors Amandine breton tradition le
fait de la musique et ça se passera
cette fois-ci du côté du parc de La
Coudre oui absolument un pôle unique et
un double événement fête de la musique
le 21 juin et sur le même site faites de
la ville donc un programme qui démarre à
partir de 16h qui va durer jusqu'à
minuit et demi absolument et sur un
programme qui est aussi très éclectique
oui ben il y aura aussi des élèves du
conservatoire de musique avec le
professeur de technique de chant
Jean-Paul Tessier et on aura aussi des
chorales des qui viennent d'associations
de la ville comme le groupe vocal
imagine ou la chorale la dalle et puis
on aura à partir de 20h30 jusqu'à minuit
et demi des artistes qui sont donc
accompagnés par le secteur music
amplifié voilà c'est des artistes avec
lesquels on travaille depuis plusieurs
années et on montre maintenant aux ini
montains voilà le résultat de leur
travail et de notre accompagnement des
thèmes de musique un peu différente
parce que je vois qu'il y a du rock il y
a du il y a du rap il y a un peu de tout
quoi oui dans la musique actuelle c'est
assez éclectique effectivement il y a
l'artiste corta donc un tout jeune
rappeur de 17 ans quand on va
enregistrer le premier EP en novembre
donc il sera là on aura aussi Hoshi qui
est une jeune artiste qui évolue pour
l'instant sur scène toute seule et qui
est en signature avec un label parisien
qui s'appelle Stayen et puis on
terminera par le groupe Blue Box dont on
vient de finir aussi un nouvel EP qui
est en promotion de cette paix
actuellement un peu partout en France et
ils viennent d'ailleurs de finir la fin
de faire la première partie du groupe
gauche
aurakam et d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
pour passer le message on reçoit le
groupe gauche le 19 décembre à la salle
Jaguar
ça veut dire que le service des musiques
amplifié permet vraiment au groupe de
monter monter c'est le but oui oui il y
a des groupes qui ont qui ont une vraie
envie de se professionnaliser qui se
structure pour ça et nous on est là pour
essayer de les aider à
obtenir leur objectif et à être visible
et repérable de structure privée
professionnelle il y a une sélection là
par exemple pour cette fête de la
musique parce que je préviens qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de groupes reçues par le
service des musiques amplifiées il y a
eu effectivement des choix à faire parce
que les années précédentes ont
permettait à une cinquantaine de
musiciens de groupe inintant de jouets
là effectivement il a fallu sélectionner
et c'est vrai qu'on a eu le parti pris
de de mettre en avant 5 artistes qui
sont en accompagnement au cinéma en tout
cas pour la dernière tranche de la Fête
de la Musique c'est-à-dire de 20h30 à
minuit et demi donc ça veut dire qu'ils
auront à peu près une plage de
une demi-heure à peu près donc c'est
largement suffisant pour qu'ils puissent
exprimer un peu tous leurs tous leurs
talents ils auront le temps de proposer
plusieurs plusieurs chansons différentes
on aura le temps de rentrer dans leur
univers tout à fait d'accord donc ça
c'est à partir de 16h donc au parc du
château de La Coudre d'habitude
les autres années on a investi donc les
dernières années l'ensemble du
territoire en allant plutôt dans les les
axes de circulation quotidien des gens
puisque c'était c'était pendant la
semaine donc c'était plus simple que on
aille vers les inondins plutôt qu'ils
viennent comme ça dans un endroit un peu
plus excentré et donc un programme
effectivement avec les petits qui de la
chorale jusqu'au rap exactement
aux horaires ça démarre vous à 17 heures
du côté de la ferme de Cauville à
voisins et c'est un peu le même principe
c'est-à-dire c'est un programme très
éclectique tout à fait en fait voisin
est une ville riche de ces associations
donc ce qu'on souhaite faire c'est de
permettre lors de cette fête de la
musique de mettre en valeur en fait
toutes les pratiques musicales qui
existent sur le territoire donc pareil
ça va également de la chorale en passant
par l'ensemble de flûte pas un Big Bang
de jazz et ensuite on termine par de la
musique amplifiée donc c'est à peu près
le même esprit fête de la musique et on
a souhaité tout concentrer sur l'espace
de covid qui est vraiment le lieu
culturel à Voisins donc c'est des
groupes aussi de voisins Bretonneux ux
exactement en répétition dans les
cadeaux tout à fait soit ils sont ils
sont issus de l'association métassos
donc ils enregistrent et pratiques dans
les studios soit d'une autre association
en fait multisond qui fait plus
qui essaie de grouper les différentes
pratiques pour que les gens puissent
s'exprimer en scène devant un public ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas lors de
la préparation de cette fête de la
musique
les services culturels c'est une fête
qui se fait en préparation enfin on
démarre pas le 21 juin enfin c'est il y
a quand même un rétroplanning assez
conséquent donc chez nous c'est un peu
sur la base du volontariat on essaie pas
trop trop doublons et que tout le monde
en fait on a limité les créneaux à une
demi-heure
à tout le monde donc les créneaux sont
limités à une demi-heure comme ça tout
le monde peut s'exprimer est-ce que
c'est vrai qu'une heure et demie après
c'est un peu compliqué et en fait oui
enfin c'est quelques mois avant et avec
un partenariat avec le service
logistique le service culturel et les
associations elles-mêmes en particulier
métasso sa voisin
les services techniques ils font un
superbe travail service événementiel
donc l'ensemble du service culturel
effectivement
donc oui oui c'est beaucoup d'agents de
la ville qui sont qui sont fédérés
autour de ce projet et c'est comme vous
le dites sur plusieurs mois
à Buc pour ces dernières fêtes de la
musique alors vous c'est plus un quelque
chose autour de l'art lyrics et des
enfants alors nous on a effectivement
changé parce que la volonté
de la Ville c'est de travailler avec nos
jeunes et nos enfants autour de projets
culturels et dernière déjà il y avait eu
un très riche pour projet culturel qui
était la création de la fameuse bande
dessinée ma ville ma ville en bulle qui
avait été encadré par deux dessinateurs
professionnels frais de Vigneault et
rock et c'était une opération qui avait
extrêmement bien marché donc cette année
pour la Fête de la musique on a la tête
dans les nuages ah oui alors ça
s'appelle la tête dans les nuages
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement
les enfants on a essayé de les regrouper
autour d'un projet culturel et
pédagogique avec effectivement pour
double axe l'art et le patrimoine
l'opéra et cette année c'est donc
l'Opéra et la ville alors la ville c'est
son passé aéronautique bien sûr c'est
pour ça qu'on y a un petit côté nuages
vous savez que but c'est la ville
berceau de l'aviation au moins on
l'appelle comme ça parce que c'est vrai
je pense et que bon et bien cette année
deux classes d'un groupe scolaire de CM1
et de CM2 ont travaillé toute l'année
sous la direction d'un
qui est compositeur metteur en scène et
chef d'orchestre et qui a aidé toute
l'année à aider les élèves à travailler
sur tous les aspects de la création d'un
spectacle musical la musique le chant
bien sûr et également la mise en scène
les costumes les
présenter samedi c'est un spectacle qui
effectivement depuis le mois de
septembre vous travaillez dessus
au Théâtre des arcades de Buc je pense
que il y aura énormément de monde qui
viendra jouer et qui viendra voir qui
viendront voir leur petit copain de
d'école et puis des petits copains de la
ville jouaient ce spectacle j'ai assisté
tout à l'heure à une à une répétition et
j'étais très étonné par la sagesse de
ses élèves ses CM1 et CM2 bon et puis on
a une classe aussi de sixième du lycée
franco-allemand qui pour les champs
aussi s'intégrera mais ça dans la dans
la partie opéra du 28 juin
est-ce que c'est beaucoup de temps de
préparation cette fête de la musique
pour les groupes est-ce que les groupes
se préparent vraiment pour cette fête de
la musique c'est spécifique est-ce
qu'ils font par exemple des choix dans
les titres de leurs morceaux pour que ce
soit le plus populaire possible alors
c'est des groupes qui sont purement
amateurs oui c'est souvent
l'aboutissement du travail de la saison
ou un objectif de travail
voilà pour les groupes qui sont plutôt
en voie de professionnalisation qui déjà
tournent tout au long de l'année c'est
une des étapes et pour les groupes
unimontins qui sont dans ce cas là c'est
une étape agréable parce qu'ils jouent
dans leur ville
un travail qui fait ou une demande en
tout cas qui est fait de la part de la
municipalité par exemple de voisins au
niveau des groupes de choisir peut-être
des chansons un peu particulières des
titres des laissons toute latitude du
choix du programme en revanche qu'on
peut constater c'est que souvent comme
je vous ai dit on limite à une
demi-heure chaque passage de groupe est
souvent donc c'est un extrait de leur
spectacle de fin d'année par contre
c'était le cas hier je suis allée
écouter l'harmonie de Saint-Quentin au
Manet et donc là ils vont reprendre cinq
titres qu'ils ont déjà joué hier vous
voyez donc c'est plutôt une sélection on
va dire de spectacle
voilà exactement
oui par exemple là l'harmonie c'est sur
le thème de musique de films donc
tout le monde s'y retrouve le but comme
vous le disiez c'est de faire une fête
de la musique tout public tout public la
fois de la musique forcément dans le mot
fête de la musique il y a de la musique
est-ce que vous vous êtes musicien je me
trouve Pascal Romano il va me dire bah
oui bien sûr je suis dire cteur de
conservatoire forcément un directeur
Conservatoire il est musicieniste est-ce
que vous pouvez vous instruments de
musique marque oui oui je suis
guitariste et auteur compositeur et
interprète
personnellement j'ai fait partie d'un
groupe vocal mais là j'ai un peu moins
le temps depuis quelques mois donc
pour pousser la chansonnette non et non
plus ou verra pas la guitare je suis à
Montigny pour travailler et mettre en
valeur les musiciens
alors c'est vrai que nous on est dans un
dans un format un petit peu par rapport
à nos collègues là de démarrage donc il
a fallu on a plutôt laissé la place
vraiment là
au
morpavien on va dire qui souhaitait dans
ce cours format c'est s'exprimer voilà
mais ça nous arrive aussi bien à moi
qu'à mes professeurs du conservatoire de
mettre la main à l'instrument pour avec
les élèves entre autres voilà pour
participer avec grand plaisir merci
Jean-Marc aujourd'hui vous êtes pas
musicien je crois je suis pas musicien
mais amateur d'opération
on va en parler on va en parler dans
quelques instants merci en tout cas à
vous d'être ne soit pas terrible pour
parler de cette fête de la musique qui
je rappelle a lieu le samedi 21 juin et
en plus ça tombe bien il va faire beau
ce week-end donc je pense qu'il y aura
du monde pour chacun chacune de vous
animations et pour être complet je vous
propose de retrouver aussi d'autres
dates dans le département
[Musique]
voilà et parmi toute cette proposer vous
avez bien sûr noté que la ville de
Rambouillet proposait plusieurs pôles
musicaux et pour ne pas ne manquer aucun
concert lors de cette fête de la musique
à Rambouillet une application web faites
de la musique a été développée par le
réseau du son du coin en partenariat
avec l'usinage chapeau programme en
temps réel de la fête de la musique à
retrouver sur sa tablette ou son
smartphone et parmi les fonctionnalités
une géolaque géolocalisation de chaque
scène une fiche par artiste la liste des
concerts en cours bref c'est très
complet pour pas manquer pour ne pas
manquer la fête de la musique à
Rambouillet et puis dernier clin d’œil
concernant cette fête de la musique cela
concerne l'initiative de l'association
artisan du monde de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui organise
une fête une journée faite de la musique
dont de 10 heures à 18h ce samedi devant
sa boutique de trappes et tous les
musiciens qui viendront jouer se verront
offrir un rafraîchissement alors sortez
vos instruments rendez-vous devant la
boutique artisan du monde à Trappes
allez nous allons rester dans le le
domaine musical dimanche 22 juin le
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
accueille dans le cadre de la douzième
édition d'enfance 300 écoliers de
l'agglomération accompagnés d'un
orchestre professionnel pour un concert
unique d'un compte musical par ici les
enfants dernier répétition avec Aurélia
Debussy
sensibiliser les plus jeunes à l'art
lyrique un projet annuel que mène depuis
plus de 10 ans l'association pour la
promotion de la musique classique à 51
Yvelines l'opération intitulée Les
enfants en scène réunissent cette année
plus de 300 jeunes des écoles de
l'agglomération
[Musique]
ce projet a démarré en 2003
l'idée c'est de transformer entre
guillemets les populations en public
c'est-à-dire que on se rend compte que
il y a beaucoup de salles de spectacles
à 50 ans en Yvelines il y a des gens qui
viennent dans les salles mais il y a des
populations qui les mettent jamais les
pieds donc pour attirer ces populations
l'idée était de s'adresser à leurs
enfants et les enfants on les met sur
scène parce que quand ils sont dans une
salle bon bah ils vont écouter mais vous
allez faire de la musique classique à
des enfants de d'école primaire qui
n'ont jamais assisté à un concert c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
difficile en revanche leur faire les
faire travailler une oeuvre et les faire
chanter et les mettre sur la scène et
bien là c'est tout autre chose parce que
les parents viennent assister au
spectacle et ils découvrent la salle et
il découvre les spectacles et c'est très
important le moment tant attendu partout
s'approche les répétitions se terminent
l'aboutissement de 7 mois de travail aux
côtés de l'orchestre
d'adulte et de la maîtrise de trappe ils
monteront sur la scène du Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce dimanche le
grand cœur des enfants interprétera le
conte musical de Marc-Olivier Dupin par
ici les enfants sur un livret divan
Grimbert une création mondiale
j'écris avec l'idée que ça va être
chanter et que ça va être mis en musique
et que il faut travailler à ce que la
les mots les paroles invite à la musique
l'idée c'est un texte accessible à des
niveaux différents de lecture pour les
enfants pour des petits pour des plus
grands pour des adultes
c'est peut-être ça les niveaux de
lecture différents qui font que tout le
monde y trouve quelque chose
on est dans une petite ville où les
enfants arrêtent de naître et qu'est-ce
qui se passe pour connaître la suite
rendez-vous dimanche 22 juin au Théâtre
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
allez on va rester encore dans le
domaine de la musique mais cette fois-ci
on va se rendre sur le samedi 28 juin
dans une semaine on va chanter en plein
air au château de Big Buc pardon c'est
la nuit de l'Opéra 8e du nom
jean-marcellier vous êtes resté en
plateau avec nous pour nous parler
justement de cette nuit de l'opéra au
programme Rigoletto de Verdi oui alors
d'abord quand je vous ai demandé si vous
jouez dans la seconde musique mais non
mais j'aime beaucoup l'opéra la nuit de
l'Opéra c'est votre votre inspiration ah
oui ça c'est vrai que ça fait ça fait 8
ans que ça dure et j'espère que ça va
continuer on a déjà le programme de
l'année prochaine et on a déjà le
programme de 2016
[Musique]
Europa classique
de Michael Vaccaro cette année
les cœurs et les cœurs sont accompagnés
par du Théâtre national de Constanta qui
est un Roumanie et sous la conduite d'un
chef d'orchestre féminin Sybille Wagner
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
Rigoletto de Verdi mais vous allez
forcément reconnaître l'air est très
très connu on va écouter un extrait de
la donna et mobile
l'étoile
[Musique]
j'aurais pu vous faire reprendre parce
que
donc
très très connu alors d'ailleurs
pourquoi toujours des œuvres très
connues pour assembler effectivement
c'est pour rassembler à maximum de
personnes c'est vrai que je crois que
l'opéra qui a le le plus marcher dans
les 8 représentations qu'on vient de
faire c'est c'est Carmen alors Carmen
c'était le je crois ah c'est le
classique et je crois que ça ça a été
quelque chose d'important et alors
désert des air connu bien sûr parce que
c'était très connu et ça permet de
regrouper un maximum de personnes autour
du thème de l'Opéra dans le théâtre de
verdure c'est donc chanter en extérieur
ça veut dire qu'il y a des contraintes
techniques je pense sont très
importantes il y a des contraintes
techniques importantes c'est sûr c'est
en extérieur c'est face au château
dans un cadre
idyllique
et vous avez un plan B alors il va faire
beau ce week-end ça va bien quand il
fait pas beau il y a toujours un plan B
non alors là c'est là que ça gêne un peu
c'est qu'on a pas de plan B mais ça fait
mais là il fait beau ça fait 7 ans qu'il
fait beau
de professionnels mais ça mobilise
beaucoup notre service culturel qui
alors évidemment au bout de la huitième
année il y a des il y a des il y a des
acteurs de répétition qui sont très
facilement mais ça nécessite quand même
un travail important et un
investissement toute personnel y compris
le personnel administratif qui donne un
coup de main lors de la soirée et de
représentation
financier important aussi de faire
dormir c'est un investissement important
mais qui est comblé si vous voulez par
tous nos sponsors qui sont toujours
présents et qui répondent chaque année
ça fait 7 ans que ça dure et chaque
année on de nouveaux sponsors
du spectacle pas de problème de votre
côté
on vient de voir à l'instant sur portage
de bicy sur le travail qui est fait avec
les écoliers de 50 ans en Yvelines sur
la scène du Théâtre National est-ce que
vous du côté de but de sur cette nuit de
l'Opéra vous associer aussi les enfants
de la commune alors ils viennent
peut-être pas chanter avec les
professionnels sur scène alors cette
année pour la première fois on a une
classe de 6e du lycée franco-allemand
puisque sur le territoire de Buck on a
la chance d'avoir un lycée
franco-allemand et une classe de 6e
chantera avec les cœurs et puis depuis
deux ans déjà on avait la participation
d'une d'une classe d'un groupe scolaire
qui faisait des une classe
à thème culturel et dont l'institutrice
adore aussi également l'opéra et les
enfants seront figurant pour Rigoletto
également ils en sont très heureux alors
dernière question rapidement vous nous
avez dit le programme est connu de
l'année prochaine donc Rigoletto pour
cette année de Verdi vous savez l'année
prochaine
c'est Madame Butterfly
de l'Opéra donc ça sera samedi 28 juin
cette édition de 7 8e et maintenant
terminée merci de l'avoir suivi et
surtout bonne fête de la musique à vous
tous
[Applaudissements]